pour en parler on retrouve en direct
joël andriantsimbazovina professeur de
droit à l'université toulouse 1 capitole
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france a alors malgré l'annoncé par le
gouvernement d'une réécriture totale de
l'article 24 ils étaient encore des
milliers à manifester hier en france le
gouvernement at il intérêt à reculer
selon vous je pense qu'il faudrait
sortir de l'affrontement entre les
manifestants et le gouvernement et
sortir de l'affrontement aussi entre
ceux qui sont favorables aux forces de
l'ordre et ceux qui sont favorables à la
liberté de manifester d'informer en fait
le problème semble être plus large les
violences qu'on voit depuis plusieurs
années équipe à gravity ne sont que le
symptôme d'un problème plus large
d'après moi c'est à dire que on a sans
doute des problèmes institutionnels plus
large la majorité gouverne mais une
partie de la population des pays
représentés à l'assemblée nationale qui
fait il ya un décalage entre l'opinion
d'une partie des français et l'opinion
de la majorité et donc comme il ya ce
décalage là on demande beaucoup de
choses aux portes de l'ordre et
notamment donc le maintien de l'ordre
pendant les manifestations
et pendant cette période là ils sont
aussi des forces de l'ordre doivent
aussi faire face à la lutte contre le
terrorisme et le grand banditisme et
donc je pense que son il faut condamner
fermement les violentes il faut lutter
contre les violences mais par ailleurs
il faudrait avoir une politique plus
globale que thème de la sécurité du
maintien de leur protection à protection
des policiers d'un côté et défense des
libertés de l'autre c'est un jeu
d'équilibriste selon vous oui c'était le
fait vraiment la difficulté toujours
dans ce type d'énergie il faut à la fois
garantir
la sécurité des français et protégée au
tissu qui assure cette sécurité
mais en même temps il faut garantir la
liberté est par ailleurs par ailleurs
les forces publiques ne doivent pas être
uniquement utilisé dans un intérêt
particulier fut-il celui des gouvernants
doit être utilisé dans l'intérêt général
on l'a dit au coeur des débats ce fameux
article 24 le parlement donc annoncer sa
réécriture
mais on le rappelle il a déjà été voté
par le parlement
du coup qu'on est il en termes de droits
alors actuellement l'assemblée je
rappelle que c'est une proposition de
loi donc c'est une opposition et de loi
émanant de deux députés elle ça implique
que il n'y a pas eu de l'avis du conseil
d'état
et il n'y a pas non plus d'études
d'impact qui limite les discussions sur
sur ce texte
donc au mois de janvier il a été le pot
de la proposition était adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat doit
l'examiner au mois de janvier 2021
entre temps le gouvernement avait
proposé une réécriture en proposant une
une commission qui régla minerais la
question des on sait que cette
proposition-là de réécriture par une
commission est très largement contraire
un autre droit constitutionnel au droit
parlementaire et il faudra donc l'été le
sénat faire le travail et en tout état
peut me semble utile sur le plan du
droit une réécriture dans le contexte
actuel paraît très difficile à réaliser
justement le gouvernement on avait calé
et quelques cafouillages récemment
autour de cette proposition de loi est
ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il a du
mal justement à gérer la situation et
que ce mouvement pourrait continuer dans
le temps si on ne fait rien je pense que
là lorsqu'il ya des affrontements
on voit bien que nous sommes dans une
impasse
et par moments il faut savoir apaiser la
tension il n'était pas pleinement ne
peut venir que de gouvernement les mots
d' emmanuel macron dans son entretien au
média brut était voilà censé apaiser
justement les esprits il n'a pas réussi
à faire passer ce message le président
de la république selon vous il me semble
qu'il faut pas des mots il faut déjà
c'est ça je crois qu'ils appelleraient
et dans le passé un an dans une autre
histoire institutionnels et des
constitutionnels il est important
parfois de savoir reconnaît on se trouve
dans une impasse qu'on retire au moins
l'article qui pose problème
il y en a d'autres vous avez montré dans
votre reportage qui lie à d'autres
dispositions de la loi qui font débat
sous l'angle des droits de l'homme et on
sait que la quasi unanimité de toutes
les instances chargées de faire
respecter des droits de l'homme que ça
soit en europe ou aux nations unies ont
souligné les difficultés que pose un
certain nombre de dispositions de cette
proposition de loi
merci beaucoup joël andriantsimbazovina
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
droit à l'université toulouse 1 capitole